nîmois de cimenter cette fois tu viens
de chez toi tu vas au boulot tu
reviennes personne tu as dit monsieur
madame vous êtes et les gaulois la vie
est belle en couleurs pourquoi diable où
vous vous arrêtez au noir bleu marine
j'ai dû nous c'est pas possible ça sert
à rien l'habille le sapeur fait jouer à
l'ebit son premier rôle qui expriment ce
qu'ils ne devaient pas cessé d'être un
vecteur de communication
mais la sape basse et c'est sur le vivre
ensemble via la bi
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour 1h30 d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenue évidemment à bonne
distance et nos reporters une émission
aujourd'hui encore consacrée à la crise
du coronavirus en france et dans le
monde
voici les titres et la france qui passe
la barre des 10000 morts liés au corps
en un virus annonce du directeur général
de la santé jérôme selle au mans il ya
quelques instants et français qui sont
entrés dans leur quatrième semaine de
confinement qui va durer martel edouard
philippe à l'assemblée il se durcit en
tout cas paris où il ne sera désormais
plus possible de faire du sport entre
10h et 19h à partir de demain concernant
le port du masque plusieurs villes comme
nice cannes pso souhaite le rendre
obligatoire est une bonne nouvelle
néanmoins en chine ça fait du bien c'est
le jour de la libération pour roanne à
la capitale de la province chinoise du
hebei debout est partie la pandémie un
confinement après une semaine de
fermeture les etats-unis eux plonge dans
le chaos
on y compte plus de 368 milka et plus de
11 mille morts c'est le nouveau foyer
mondial du comité 19
[Musique]
c'est chez vous c'est donc le mot
d'ordre on l'aura compris si cet
isolement doit permettre d'endiguer la
pandémie n'est pas sans effet sur la
santé mentale et peut occasionner un
stress post traumatique parfois des
sentiments de frustration de confusion
et de colère selon une étude parue dans
résidence est
nous verrons que nous sommes pas tous
égaux face à cette épreuve est en pleine
crise du cornât virus les contrôles des
forces de l'ordre font débat des
associations dénoncent certains
contrôles policiers violents qui aurait
fuité sur les réseaux sociaux depuis le
début du confinement
plusieurs organisations à les dénoncer
appelle le ministre d'intérieur et de
directeur général de la police au
respect des procédures
[Musique]
la france passe par la barre des 10000
morts avec 10 1328 décès depuis le 1er
mars annoncent de jerôme seine au mans
il y à quelques minutes selon directeur
général de la santé la france n'est pas
je cite encore au pic épidémique mais
dans la phase ascendante
il a également rappelé que le
confinement à l'élu ray et appelle les
ehpad à remonter leurs besoins le plus
rapidement possible écouté depuis le 1er
mars
en additionnant les décès survenus à
l'hôpital et ceux survenus au sein des
établissements médico sociaux et en
particulier les ehpad
nous déplorons 10300 28 décès pour faire
face à l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes âgées atteintes du coc u19 les
ehpad ont besoin de renfort je les
invite donc à remonter le plus vite
possible leurs besoins aux agences
régionales de santé avec des détails
avec des expressions précises pour que
nous leur trouvions rapidement et
collectivement les solutions et les
autorités sanitaires recommandent le
port du masque alors que le gouvernement
y étaient hostiles
il ya encore quelques jours alors
faut-il oui ou non le porter ce masque
le mini de la santé olivier ferrand a
réaffirmé la position de la france
aujourd'hui écoutés
il n'y a aucune décision de
recommandations de port du masque ni
obligatoire ni recommandé en tout cas à
ce stade pour la population générale
s'il s'avère que le port d'un masque en
population générale pouvait permettre de
renforcer l'efficacité du dispositif si
les recommandations des scientifiques
allaient dans ce sens alors nous serions
amenés à communiquer en ce sens mais à
ce stade je ne mendie la doctrine n'a
pas évolué alors non obligatoire pour le
gouvernement certaines villes quand même
ont décidé d'aller plus loin et ne pas
attendre assaut dans les hauts-de-seine
par exemple philippe laurent le maire de
la ville a pris un arrêté pour obliger
les habitants se couvrir le nez et le
visage avant de sortir de chez eux tous
les habitants de plus de 10 ans sont
concernés et tous types de masques
autorisé même une écharpe ou un foulard
tant que le nez et la bouche sont
couverts les contrevenants risquent une
amende de 38 euros nos équipes sont
allées à la rencontre des habitants de
la ville
je trouve que c'est bien pour protéger
la population mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya des masques nulle part donc
comment on va faire pour ce pour en
acheter ou s'en procurer que je vais
mettre un truc sur le champ le visage
qu'il ya une espèce de kaboul de moto
quoique ça c'est sûr que c'est exagéré
c'est qu'on ne rencontre personne ne
fait en fait je pense que je vais très
comme ça
il a parlé de masse qu'il a parlé de
protection donc reza naturellement parce
que les basses et la question où les
chercher je pense est une bonne chose ça
fait partie des barrières qui promettent
un mois je ne suis pas content parce que
je pense que si ça peut protéger
l'ensemble des personnes de la région
maintenant mieux
philippe laurent le maire de sceaux nous
expliquer pourquoi il a mis en place ce
décret en effet j'ai été amené à prendre
cette décision pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que j'ai reçu un certain
nombre d'avis d'experts médicaux comme
des gens tout le monde devait notamment
david de l'académie de médecine qui est
une institution indépendante et qui n'a
subi de pression de personne et qui m'a
semblé donc tout à fait pertinente à
savoir qu' il vaut mieux se couvrir avec
quoi que ce soit plutôt que ne rien
faire du tout combien chose et puis la
deuxième chose c'est que j'ai été tout
de même un peu surpris en réalité deux
du nombre de personnes qui étaient dans
la rue qui se promenaient parce que
c'est vraiment l'expression pendant tout
le week-end et que beaucoup de gens se
croisent et de manière très proche
certains qui s'était protégée la bouche
le nez et d'autres qui ne l'avait pas
fait et j'ai estimé qu'il était de santé
publique de salubrité publique
le faire en sorte que tout le monde se
protègent la bouche et le nez lorsqu'il
est sur l'espace public et face à la
pénurie de masques plusieurs villes ont
donc a pris les devants dans la
métropole de bordeaux a annoncé
aujourd'hui leur intention de commander
il sent mille masque en tissu pour
équiper chacun des habitants de
l'agglomération bordeaux qui s'est en
fait inspirée de l'exemple niçois
le maire christian estrosi s'est engagé
à fournir un masque en tissu lavable et
réutilisable à tous les habitants et le
port sera obligatoire pour chaque sortie
à paris anne hidalgo prévoir l d'en
mettre deux millions à disposition des
parisiens
et alors que la france est entrée
aujourd'hui dans sa quatrième semaine de
confinement edouard philippe a prévenu
que cela allait durer
durée encore lors de la séance des
questions au gouvernement écouter le
premier ministre donc aujourd'hui c'est
l'heure du confinement et lors du
confinement va durer et c'est tout à
fait difficile à supporter pour beaucoup
de français j'en ai parfaitement
conscience mais c'est indispensable si
nous ne voulons pas nous retrouver dans
une situation qui serait pire encore que
celle que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
et pour en parler nous sommes avec nice
buisson membre de l'académie de médecine
bonsoir arrivent huit sont merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france un
confinement qui a encore appelé à durer
manifestation c'est une bonne chose pour
le médecin que vous êtes bien entendu ce
confinement doit durer tant qu'il sera
nécessaire
il est il est obligatoire pour l'instant
avec un objectif qui est de diminuer la
charge des hôpitaux notamment au niveau
de service de réanimation qui sont
submergés est temps que ces services de
réanimation seront en difficulté
le confinement devrait être maintenu et
ce qui est très inquiétant c'est de voir
effectivement le comportement d'une
faible d'une minorité de la population
mais qui est quand même suffisamment
importants pour maintenir la
transmission comportement irresponsable
de personnes qui ne respectent pas le
confinement
c'est la raison pour laquelle cision 2-2
le devrait être prise non pas simplement
à l'échelon de ville qu'ils font très
bien comme comme sow mais à l'échelon
national
il faut savoir si on veut qu on a passé
le cap des dix mille victimes
est-ce qu'on veut encore des mets mort
dans les semaines qui suivent
c'est un c'est vraiment une
responsabilité collective dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons et je pense qu'il
faut passer
malheureusement par des mesures assez
coercitives des mesures d'obligations le
haut comme nous en sommes il veut selon
vous un petit peu perdu à un moment
donné pour un problème de réseau ou tout
simplement j'imagine qu'en parlant de
saut vous faisiez
allusion au port du masque j'espère ne
pas me tromper puisqu'on a été
effectivement coupé pendant ce moment
pour vous est ce qu'il faut ou non le
rendre obligatoire ce match sachant
évidemment on ne le dit pas franchement
mais tout simplement on n'a pas les
moyens de le rendre obligatoire en ce
moment puisque tout simplement d'un on
les a passés maffre mais selon vous ce
serait une bonne chose de le rendre
obligatoire si on pouvait s'est félicité
pendant la coupure je disais que
l'initiative du maire de sceaux est tout
à fait louable mais elle devrait être
national pas limité à celle des loups
ile de france
ça doit être nationale parce que le
l'épidémie et pour tout pays même si
elles ne couvrent de façon inégale de
façon hétérogène il faut que tout tout
le monde soit conscient du fait que il
est potentiellement porteurs du virus
qu'il peut le transmettre aux personnes
qui l'entourent et donc le fait de
porter un masque dans les espaces
publics va arrêter du moins deux ans
grand en partie les risques de
transmission alors le fait de dire oui
mais des masques nous ne rêvons pas ça
n'est pas recevable à l'heure actuelle
on sait très bien maintenant vous avez
sur tous les sites internet des conseils
très simple pour fabriquer avec selon
qu'on dispose chez soi avec du tissu
avec du coton avec eux matériel qu'on
trouve partout on peut confectionner un
masque carratu une efficacité
il sera même plus efficace qu'une la
simple écharpe miss devant son nez il
faut pouvoir couvrir sans les sa bouche
pendant plusieurs heures avec un tissu
qui pourrait être réutilisables lavables
et c'est quand même des moyens qui ne
sont pas très compliqué avant on puisse
disposer de fourniture de masques par le
gouvernement si cela doit venir un jour
je voulais m'arrêter quelques instants
sur les chiffres qu'on appelle c'est
aujourd'hui la barre des 10000 morts
dans notre pays
jérôme sainement qui précise que le pic
n'est pas encore atteint alors que nous
sommes confinés depuis maintenant trois
semaines révolue est ce que le médecin
qu'on vous ait
que vous êtes vous apporter une
explication oui l'explication c'est que
bon d'abord il ya un retard entre la
contamination l'apparition des symptômes
on sait que c'est en moyenne cinq six
jours de d'incubation
donc lorsqu'on applique des mesures il
faut toujours observé un certain retard
pour observer leurs effets mais quoi
qu'il en soit façon générale ce que nous
avons observé au cours du week-end
dernier et lé ces jours ci c'est que une
partie de la population ne respecte pas
le confinement et ça c'est qu'on n'a pas
d'autre moyen de lutter contre cette
épidémie
nous n'avons pas de traitement efficace
antiviral nous n'avons pas encore de
vaccin donc le seul moyen d'arrêter
cette épidémie c'est de stopper la
transmission pour stopper la
transmission ce sont les mesures
barrières et le port du masque peut se
rajouter peut augmenter l'efficacité des
mesures barrières comme la distanciation
sociale et le fait de se laver les mains
très régulièrement et c'est alors
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
évidemment test de traitement en cours
est ce qu'il y en a un qui apporte et
qui suscite peut-être plus d'espoir il
faut de tous les tests de tous les
traitements qui sont actuellement en
cours d'évaluation
pour l'instant on ne peut pas dire grand
chose n'a pas de recul suffisant pour
dire tel test marche mieux que d'autres
je pense que celui qui peut actuellement
donner le plus d'espoir c'est
probablement le l'immunothérapie passive
c'est-à-dire de l'utilisation de ces
roms de convalescents sous forme de
d'anticorps à eux qu'on va purifier on
appelle ça des immunoglobulines hyper
immune combats ont fait des poules de
plasma chaidron mélange le plasma de
plusieurs personnes qui sont
convalescente de la maladie et on va
purifier leurs anticorps en injectant
ces anticorps aux personnes qui sont
début de maladie
on veut les aider à se défendre contre
l'infection et à éliminer le virus
ça c'est une bon 7 du ca demande bien
vu un certain délai de préparation se
demande des études plus poussées mais ça
a déjà montré son efficacité et je pense
que cette voie là me semble actuellement
plus sûr et plus avancé que les
molécules antivirales qui sont en cours
de test
on a compris évidemment que vous
défendiez c'est certainement logique le
confinement strict aujourd'hui le
premier ministre refuse à parler de
stratégies de déconfinement est-ce que
vous avez une préférence un conseil
justement concernant sa stratégie on a
évoqué plusieurs choses
le déconfinement région par région par
tranche d'âge également quelle est votre
radio alors nous mon avis et c'est
l'avis de mes collègues aussi de
l'académie de médecine parce que nous
travaillons en gros peut nous étudions
nous prenons beaucoup d'avis pour
formuler une recommandation
il nous semble que la meilleure
stratégie sera le moment venu de
procéder au dégoût déconfinement à
l'échelon régional
parce qu'elle est honoré de l'échelon
régional offre des possibilités de
décision et d'application des mesures
qui ont été prises meilleur et plus plus
réalisable que d'un autre et flon avec
la préfecture avec l' agence régionale
de santé
il est possible donc de d'encadrer les
mesures qui ont été décidées
l'autre stratégie qui est par tranche
d'âge alors intellectuellement ça peut
être intéressant on peut comprendre que
puisque les personnes âgées les
personnes à risque seraient donc
resterait en confinement alors que les
personnes qui sont moins à risque les
plus jeunes donc les enfants qui vont à
l'école les étudiants les piles et tous
les actifs pourrait reprendre le travail
ces soldes c'est séduisant donc bien sûr
mais c'est impraticable parce que la
plupart de ces personnes vivent en
famille et on imagine que ce sera très
difficile de mettre ces mesures en
pratique à l'échelon des familles dans
sous le même toit vous avez des confiné
des non confiné qui vont vivre ensemble
comment faire comment éviter que la
transmission se fasse au niveau faible
yann on sait actuellement que c'est dans
les maisons dans les familles dans les
foyers que l'essentiel de la
transmission se fait et parce que c'est
là que c'est le plus difficile à éviter
aujourd'hui il ya aussi vainement la
question des tests quand on parle de
déconfinement cela vous paraît être une
des solutions pas miracle mais en tout
cas qui contribuera peut-être accélérer
ce déconfinement ça peut aider mes roues
on met les tests on donne beaucoup trop
d'importance aux tests alors que je suis
microbiologiste que je connais je crois
beaucoup bien entendu à l'apport du
laboratoire mais les tests il faut pas
en attendre trop il faut pas surtout en
parler trop tôt parce que les tests on
ne les a pas encore les tests qui sont
actuellement sur le marché sont en cours
d'évaluation
la plupart ont été fabriqués en chine
certains tests ont été évalués se sont
révélés de mauvaise qualité donc ne
seront pas utilisées donc il faut
attendre encore un petit peu on va avoir
des tests mais vous savez c'est très
long de faire des tests c'est un virus
qu'on ne connaissait pas encore il ya
trois mois donc le temps d'identifier le
virus d'identifier les moyens donc les
reçoivent
le génome de ça a été fait très
rapidement pour mettre en pratique la
paix sert pour détecter le génome viral
mais après détecter les antigènes
principaux qui vont servir à faire les
tests sérologiques c'était rechercher
des anticorps chez les personnes ça
c'est plus long c'est des tests qui
demande d'être longuement soisy finalisé
évalué avant de pouvoir les utiliser et
en tirer quelque chose parce qu'on peut
pas utiliser des tests sans savoir ce
qu'ils valent
les tests ont deux qualités c'est la
sensibilité et la spécificité et si on
ne connaît pas ses taux de sensibilité
de spécificités on ne sait pas très bien
quelle utilisation stratégique
on pourra en faire merci beaucoup yves
800 membres de l'académie
de médecine d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france merci à vous alors
cette question évidemment comment allons
nous sortir du confinement viens d'en
parler une fois l'épidémie derrière nous
la question ne se pose évidemment pas
qu'en france chez nos voisins européens
les gouvernants les gouvernement planche
sur des mesures de sortie de crise pour
les semaines ou pour les mois à venir
certains pays comme l'italie ou
l'autriche annonce déjà un déconfinement
prudent et progressif voici quelques
explications en images
[Musique]
nous
m
[Musique]
le
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais
oui
[Musique]
mais
et pour parler de cette question du
déconfinement jugée prématurée par le
premier ministre nous sommes avec
alexandre de béchio journaliste bonsoir
alexandre ii vécurent merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france
les voisins européens on est un petit
peu jaloux inquiet non une stratégie de
déconfinement en france on reste dans le
flou en musique ça va durer mais enfin
aucun mot en tout cas sur une éventuelle
stratégie de sortie quelle est votre
réaction comment vous vous l'expliquer
bah je pense qu'on peut les expliquer
puisque on a bien compris que pour des
cons fine et il fallait avoir les moyens
nécessaires c'est à dire les masques et
les tests pour pouvoir éventuellement
isoler les personnes malades les masques
pour éviter la diffusion du virus et
comme l'état n'est pas en capacité
voilà deux de fournir tout cela et c'est
qu'il est mort il parle trop tôt pour
parler de déconfinement mais on peut
s'interroger sur la stratégie qui
conduit à adopter
jean yves le drian dîner spectacle
on l'attendait des masques commandés en
chine pour juin
est ce qu'il faudrait pas mettre en
place une stratégie de production à ce
qu'il aura pas fallu le faire avancer
des question qu'on peut se poser on peut
se demander si tous les moyens sont mis
en oeuvre pour que l'état puisque agir
et fournir le matériel nécessaire à ceux
des confinement et oui mais dans le même
temps olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé nous dit tout simplement sur
l'épaule de porc de ces masques que la
question restait ouverte pour l'instant
il n'y a ni obligation ni même
recommandation en a entendu nos mises de
la santé tout à l'heure oui je pense qu
en com comme depuis le début la
stratégie et la communication s'adapte à
la situation de pénurie je pense que là
on est toujours malheureusement dans
cette situation de quel une pénurie du
coup olivier est un ovni explique
effectivement il n'y aura pas
d'obligation du match je pense que si
nous avions les basques a à disposition
il en serait
les trois mois aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron s'est rendu en seine saint denis
a on l'a vu dans les rues d'ailleurs
bien entouré par les habitants la
remercier ces mêmes habitants qui
respecte le confinement et a été
interpellé d'ailleurs sur le monde
d'équipements pour les soignants ces
images justement qui ont circulé sur les
réseaux sociaux du président de la
république avec du monde glutineux
autour quel effet ça peut faire quand on
demande aux français de respecter
strictement le confinement est ce que
c'est une bonne communication la part du
président de la république selon vous
oui je pense qu'il ya une forme
d'incohérence dans cette communication
il y avait sans doute la volonté de
rappeler qu'il était le président de
tous les français y compris bien sûr du
territoire de la seine saint denis qui
est durement touchée par le corona des
routes mais je pense que l'effet ben
elle va être plutôt négatif puisqu'il a
provoqué autour de lui un attroupement
elle n'a donc pas à montrer l'exemple
duration sec
chauvin département qu'il ya beaucoup de
cas c'est parce qu'il ya aussi des zones
de non droit mais aussi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de dettes soignante le
travailleuses des ehpad je suis pas sûr
qu elle avait besoin de ce signal la ja
pas comme un signal s'il a le monde e2
de légèreté
et donc je crois que quand il va voir
lui même des images volées baduel à quoi
il va se rendre compte qu'une opération
de communication risque hélas de se
retourner contre lui pour reparler de ce
déconfinement aujourd'hui l'autriche a
on l'a vu mais pas que d'ailleurs un
l'italie l'autriche et premier pays
européen à annoncer cette stratégie de
déconfinement avec la réouverture des
magasins de certains magasins au 14
avril autriche qui affiche 204 morts sur
8,8 millions d'habitants pourquoi s'en
sort-il mieux que nous ces autrichiens
je pense qu'au soutien à la solidité du
système de santé à l'anticipation la
capacité ou pas de produire des masses
par exemple également voient qu'il
peuvent en produire plusieurs centaines
de milliers voire plusieurs millions par
par semaine donc donc en fonction de ses
moyens là effectivement le déconfinement
peut être envisagé beaucoup plus
rapidement hélas comme je le disais tout
à l'heure on est dans un dans une
gestion de la pénurie les révèle la
faiblesse d'un système de pensée de le
penser le sentais qu'on présentait comme
comme extrêmement fort en europe et qui
se révèle finalement beaucoup plus
fragile avec un suffisamment de l'udps
hôpitaux a suffisamment de deux
respirateurs la stratégie du confinement
elle est mise en place un impôt
finalement y est allé la vague et parce
qu'on n'a pas forcément les moyens
d'accueillir trop de personnes en même
temps dans les services hospitaliers et
donc tant qu'on ne pas lui pas à ces
défaillances
eh bien on en reste à cette stratégie
défensive d'autres pays ont pu déployer
une stratégie plus offensive mais parce
qu'ils avaient finalement une
organisation de l'état système de santé
un système de production industrielle
plus solides finale banque le neutron
dernière question alexandre de voeux de
vecchio vous êtes
observateur évidemment de cette société
française depuis longtemps vous êtes
journaliste vous écrivez dans le figaro
comment vous percevez la réaction des
français justement par rapport à cette
gestion de la crise de la part du
gouvernement
je pense que les français font preuve de
sérénité je crois quoi qu'on en dise les
mesures de confinement sont plutôt
respectée par la majorité des français
il faut souligner aussi le courage des
premières lignes
bien sûr des soignants mais aussi les
travail des départs des caissières d'une
france invisible dont on perçoit
aujourd'hui l'utilité
les français ont conscience que il nous
faut pas verser peut-être en ce moment
dans les polémiques inutiles mais sans
doute on ventile de la mémoire et
nautile toutes les défaillances tous les
problèmes stratégiques auxquels la
france est confrontée et l'heure du
bilan
sans doute sans doute viendra je pense
qu'il n'est pas souhaitable en tous les
cas que le confinement se maintiennent
trop longtemps ne serait ce que par des
conséquences économiques qui pourraient
être pires finalement que les pros
séquence anitea d'où l'intérêt de
déployer le plus rapidement possible une
stratégie efficace il faut en passer par
des réquisitions une forme de
planification pour produire très vite
des basques je pense qu'il faut le faire
qu'il faut maintenant sortir de cette
bureaucratie qui nous ralentit depuis le
début
merci alexandre ii vecchio d'avoir été
en direct avec nous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants
elle nous partirons justement en
autriche en viens d'en parler premier
pays de l'union européenne a détaillé un
calendrier de sortie crise quatre
semaines après le début du confinement
puis direction le royaume uni où le
premier ministre boris johnson touché
par le corps d'un virus est en soins
intensifs depuis hier soir dominique
arabe ministre des affaires étrangères
assure l'intérim
[Musique]
la prévision de pib sont sont très
inférieurs à ce qu'on avait au départ
elle s'aggrave
est ce que finalement les gouvernements
ne sont pas en train de prendre
conscience de la gravité qui est des
attentes les prévisions monsieur le
maire sont une grotesque les unes que
les autres n'y a pas un gouvernement
aujourd'hui il n'ya pas évidemment un
analyste le mans qui sait exactement ce
peut se combattre honte sur la tête
en france il ya en europe d'ailleurs les
banques sont au plus mal
aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
banquiers se se couchent le soir
en trois ans les doigts qui épate banton
le lendemain dites vous bien que 2008
c'était une crisette ça n'a strictement
rien à voir on est dans quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas connue depuis des siècles
et des siècles
[Musique]
paris 2024 vos arguments messieurs êtes
vous pour ou contre
avant moi je suis tout à fait pour mais
pas n'importe quel prix et il est hors
de question qu'une chance d'organiser
les jeux olympiques se transforme en une
véritable malédiction comme c'est le cas
très souvent moi je vais représenter le
contre parce que pour moi les jeux
olympiques c'est véritablement
l'expression du vieux monde c'est à dire
qui ne prend jamais en compte la
question climatique la question sociale
la question environnementale
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer donc ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est vraiment
contrôlé au centime près jour par jour
ce budget est joué la transparence
complète tous les acteurs qu'ils soient
publics qu'ils soient privés ou on a
déjà un budget qui n'est pas tu n'es pas
sérieux et que oui ça veut dire que
nécessairement ça va être dépassé
paris fait beaucoup plus attention que
ses prédécesseurs aux questions vers non
seulement parce que c'est à la mode mais
aussi parce que le seuil haut c'est
quand même aperçu a senti passer le vent
du boulet
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
france
il est donc 20h30 heure française
deuxième partie d'émission largement
consacrée à la crise du corps d'un virus
dans le monde
en autriche le déconfinement est donc
lancée il s'agit du premier pays
européen qui annonce la réouverture de
ces commerces
ce sera pour le 14 avril pour ceux d'une
surface de moins de 400 mètres carrés
pour le reste il faudra patienter mi mai
notamment pour les hôtels et restaurants
selon certains autrichien cette décision
n'est pas une raison pour relâcher les
précautions face au virus a est filmé et
à masquer grande finesse je me sens
beaucoup mieux avec un masque et je
pense que tout le monde devrait faire
cela toujours porter un masque
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si les restrictions ont
été supprimés trop tôt
je pense que le relâchement de la
fermeture est un pas vers l'économie
certaines entreprises ont été autorisés
à ouvrir leurs portes
toute cette situation m'a affecté car
j'ai une petite entreprise non loin
d'ici mais je pense qu'il est trop tôt
pour être trop optimistes
je me sens relativement en sécurité
je mets un masque quand je vais dans un
magasin où il ya beaucoup de monde mais
cela n'a pas de sens de le porter à
l'extérieur on parle et nous sommes avec
patrick badauds expatriés français
vivant à vienne depuis maintenant près
de 15 ans bonsoir patrick abbado verte
d'être avec nous en direct la défense
d'avoir accepté de nous parler de cette
situation
autrichienne qui on doit bien lire nous
fait parfois un petit peu en ville la
situation semble être en tout cas moins
pire si j'ose dire en autriche 2 104
morts pour le bilan sur vingt huit 28
millions d'habitants
selon vous qui connaissez les deux pays
pourquoi les autrichiens s'en sortent
mieux que nous on doit d'abord donc je
pense que l'autriche a réagi très vite à
la situation
donc en prenant très rapidement les
mesures qui s'imposaient et donc ce
qu'on a pu constater aussi c'est que
dans l'ensemble la population semble
bien respecter les mesures de
confinement et les restrictions qui ont
été prescrites et donc bon en fait ces
mesures sont apparus aussi un moment en
fait tous les les chiffres et de
l'infection n'était pas encore très
important en fait alors c'est vrai que
on dit souvent oui d'autriche qui a
réagi plus vite d'ailleurs c'est ce que
dit le chancelier courte ça nous avons
agi plus vite plus drastiquement que
d'autres pays
dans le même temps mais j'ai regardé les
chiffres l'épidémie est arrivé au même
moment en autriche le confinement de la
population a eu lieu un jour près la
même date le 15 mars
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas d'autres
pistes vous dit peut-être des
autrichiens qui respectent de manière
extrêmement stricte c'est ça qui ressort
en tout cas dans le pays pour la
réussite de cette stratégie
je pense pas que moi non plus le seul
critère
bon maintenant bon il a été décidé en
fait de la semaine dernière que le pas
le port du masque serait obligatoire
dans les supermarchés donc donc à mon
avis ça c'est une des mesures aussi qui
peut contribuer en fait
et endiguer en fait l'épidémie non c'est
vrai qu'on a vu dans des reportages sur
l'autriche des masques tout simplement
être distribués à foison à toutes les
personnes qui entraient dans les
supermarchés vous vous l'avez vécu vous
même cette distribution de marche de
masques pardon dans les magasins oui
effectivement j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller
faire les courses le week-end dernier
donc on va effectivement fourni un
masque et se sont donc oui excusez moi
bon par contre c'est vrai que comme
cette mesure n'a été annoncée
il a été prévu que depuis le milieu de
la semaine dernière bon il y avait il y
avait encore des difficultés
d'approvisionnement et je suis allé dans
un autre supermarché où il y avait plus
de match que les bons depuis lundi en
fait le port et du masque est vraiment
obligatoire dans toutes les les
supermarchés et depuis ce temps là je
n'ai pas eu l'occasion d'y retourner
donc je verrais bien la prochaine fois
s'il est si les matchs que sont bien
disponibles en toute occasion
comment les autres et chiens vivent
qu'ils cette séquence d'abord le
confinement et maintenant cette
stratégie de déconfinement qu'est ce qui
est dit sur place
je pense que le fait d'avoir annoncé des
mesures d'assouplissement a été un grand
soulagement pour tout le monde puisque
bon ça fait maintenant trois semaines
que nous vivons cette situation et même
si chacun essaye de tirer le meilleur de
la situation c'est quand même une
situation pesante
donc je pense que pour ça on peut pas
dire que les autres et gien le lit
forcément mieux que dans d'autres pays
voilà donc maintenant bon bain attendons
de voir si cette tendance se poursuit
tout ce qui fait justement que les
chiffres de l'infection les les chiffres
d'infection temps de ralentissement et
que et après bonbons il faut pas non
plus trop possibilités des choses à mon
avis est ce que les autrichiens
craignent cette fameuse 2
vague dont on parle souvent je ne
pourrais pas dire ça mais bon je pense
que il reste prudent avant tout est bon
le gouvernement a bien dit que il
fallait ne pas trop se précipiter bon le
week-end dernier il y avait une
polémique puisque le ministre de la
santé avait annoncé par erreur que les
néracais les rassemblements familiaux
pourraient être autorisées pour les
fêtes de pâques et devront aussi a été
démentie le jour d'après parce que avait
entraîné certaines conclusions dans la
population en fait merci beaucoup pour
votre témoignage patrick bidaud je
rappelle vous êtes non plus et français
vivante en autriche depuis près de 15
ans merci à vous et chiffre record au
royaume uni triste record évidemment
avec 766 décès lors des 24 dernières
heures
une situation alarmante alors que boris
johnson est en soins intensifs depuis
hier soir son état de santé s'est
rapidement dégradée il souffre du virus
depuis le 27 mars le premier ministre
qui respire désormais sans aucune
assistance selon dominique rabat le met
des affaires étrangères emmanuel macron
lui ai adressé un message de soutien
selon vladimir poutine l'optimisme et
l'humour de boris johnson l'aideront à
guérir le chef de la diplomatie de
microbes qui donc que le remplace donne
de ses nouvelles écoutes et je peux vous
dire qu'il reçoit les meilleurs soins de
l'excellente équipe médicale de
l'hôpital saint thomas
il est resté stable pendant la nuit il
reçoit un traitement standard à
l'oxygène et respire sans aucune
assistance
il n'a pas besoin de ventilation
mécanique ni d'assistance respiratoire
non-invasive il reste de bonne humeur et
conformément à la pratique clinique
habituel ces progrès continue d'être
suivi de près en soins intensifs et nous
vous tiendrons au courant de l'état de
santé du premier ministre dès qu'il y
aura des développements importants
le placement en soins intensifs de
brighton sun a touché évidemment les
longs de venir écouter
avec ces terribles pour n'importe quelle
famille je pense surtout à sa fiancée
qui est enceinte c'est vraiment une
situation horrible pour eux en tant que
famille je ne suis pas d'accord avec ses
idées politiques mais je leur souhaite
vraiment où le meilleur parce que c'est
une situation vraiment angoissante pour
n'importe quelle famille et n'importe
quelle personne on n'en sait pas
beaucoup sur cette maladie
je pense qu'ils bénéficient des
meilleurs soins j'espère simplement que
le reste de la population britannique
sera aussi bien soigné mais
malheureusement ça ne sera pas le cas
c'est assez choquant et ça montre aussi
que ça peut toucher n'importe qui je
pense que ça fait vraiment passer le
message que ça peut affecter tout le
monde malade c'est donc à dominique
rabat qui a pris sa place le temps son
absence retour en images sur le parcours
du bras droit du premier ministre
britannique
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour revenir justement son inquiétude
au royaume uni nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec john mc tiernan
ancien conseiller de tony blair c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir john mc tiernan merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur c'est
paris à un premier ministre actuellement
hospitalisé pour kobe de 19 comment
vit-on cette séquence au royaume uni je
prends très au sérieux
que ce soit par ses opposants politiques
par les journalistes que par le jeu
prend publics qui sont très inquiet a
envoyé un premier ministre s'y mélangent
peut-être à l'hôpital
la seule question à part l'espoir qui
suit en général c'est pourquoi at il
fallu autant de temps sur deux choses
avant qu'ils révèlent la vérité au sulky
à concernant son état de santé
car pendant dix jours il sa maladie
empiré ces cas était une telle période
il est très difficile de ne pas avoir à
un premier ministre en pleine santé vous
mettez en cause évidemment
d'ailleurs c'est le cas dans souvent
dans plusieurs pays on l'a su dans notre
passé quand jacques chirac que notre
président à l'époque avait été
hospitalisé c'est compliqué d'avoir une
une transparence sur l'état de santé des
présidents on l'avait aussi avec
frédéric mitterrand en d'autres frédéric
françois pardon des mois un mitterrand
en d'autres temps il ya aussi ce
problème selon vous de transparence au
royaume uni sur l'état de santé des
dirigeants on a peu communiqué à votre
goût j'étais tellement je pense qu'on a
manqué de communication
le premier mousserie disais à tout le
monde de bien se laver les mains de et
garder ses distances suffisante de se
confirmer le cas échéant
et puis voilà qu'il a essayé de
continuer à travailler alors qu'il avait
admis avoir le navire et il a essayé de
continuer comme si il n'y avait aucune
différence et pourtant le savons tous
parce que nous sommes malades ne serait
ce qu'avec mac do to me
ici le travailler correctement et avec
le corps navire est ce qu'il ya un plus
virulente que la grippe
il aurait dû dès le départ je vais
montrer aux gens qui le prenaient au
sérieux
il aurait dû s'arrêter et donner à la
suppléance à quelqu'un d'autre alors à
l'invers ça on a vu il ya encore
peut-être pas quelques jours mais
quelques petites semaines morrison
serrer des mains voire des propos voilà
qui montrait qu'il ne prenait pas
nécessairement au sérieux cette maladie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les britanniques
lui en tiennent rigueur
je pense que les gens prennent la
situation très au sérieux nous avions
constaté un effondrement du nombre des
personnes qui se déplacent qui a diminué
de 10% par rapport à d'habitude tout
comme il s'agit que des travailleurs
sexuels la plupart des gens restent à la
maison les mains vides soit faite par
les gens bien sûr qu'ils font du sport
donc que les gens sont inquiets pour
eux-mêmes pour l'heure prévue pour leur
famille et surtout qu'ils sont inquiets
tout le premier but et ils ne sont pas
encore très à jamais où nous la
reprocher quelque chose à quelqu'un
ils commencent à se poser la question de
la sortie de crise et justement
concernant cette sortie de crise
quelle est la situation au royaume uni
on voit qu'en france on nous promet que
la situation de confinement vad va durer
et on se refuse le premier ministre en
tout cas évoqué la sortie de crise la
stratégie de déconfinement est ce que
c'est la même chose pour vous au royaume
uni et le premier ministre a juste à
l'origine ici que cet échange de
confinement serait revu après trois
semaines et il est maintenant
hospitalisé les trois semaines arrive
bientôt
m certains que le confinement
être prolongé nous attendrons la fin de
mai avant qu'il ait des changements
significatifs car nous pouvons constater
un impact mais car la capitalisation la
préparation des menus le ya toujours une
hausse des décès et personnes du
gouvernement n'a vraiment de stratégie
pour une sortie de confort
c'est dans quelles conditions
y aura-t-il les dépistages
supplémentaires carbone une des pistes
ont pas encore systématiquement aurélie
roulement tout le monde sait que nous
sommes à long terme dans le confinement
parle effectivement beaucoup ici quand
on parle de déconfinement de tests de
masquer ce que au royaume uni est-ce
qu'on est un peu mieux lotie au niveau
des masques ou yat-il comme en france
une pénurie
effectivement il ya pénurie au niveau
des tests comme lui veut des masques
n'avons pas assez de masques passe à ces
deux tests ne serait ce que pour les
personnels de santé les personnels de
soins qui s'occupe des personnes âgées
ou des personnes malades de l'hôpital
donc j'ai l'impression qu'il faudra pas
mal de temps avant que nous ayons assez
de masques à ces deux tests afin de
commencer à penser à
arrêté le confinement avec le port du
masque afin de nous rediriger vers une
vie normale aujourd'hui telle est la
situation dans les hôpitaux britanniques
y à t'il comme en france en tout cas
dans les régions très touchées
une saturation des services de
réanimation notamment les hôpitaux à
londres ce sont quasiment pleins mais
ouvert un hôpital temporaire à londres
avec des centaines de vies qui ne sont
pas encore tous utilisés en tout cas les
il était plus en plus de monde dans les
hôpitaux
beaucoup de salles par exemple des
théâtres d'opération sont et transformer
en unité pour les galas du coroner est
douce donc nous manquons d'équipements
de protection personnelle mais également
de respirateurs donc qu'on gagnera des
tests et nous avons encore des prairies
sont certains
le système de santé doit s'en accommoder
une dernière petite question pour parler
au delà de la crise du coronavirus on
sait que boris johnson est entre
guillemets l'homme du bric site en tout
cas voilà il a réussi à avancer plus
vite que theresa may l'a fait avant lui
est ce que les britanniques auront
peut-être m'excitait ce qu'ils sont
inquiets ou la crise du corps d'un virus
a tout balayé derrière elle la plupart
des gens existent
ça fait maintenant partie du passé nous
sommes en plein dans la crise comme l'a
fait le gouvernement dit au niveau
politique que les échéances seront
maintenus nous ferons monnaie européenne
avec un accord d'ici la fin de l'année
je ne pense pas que quiconque que je
connaisse au gouvernement aucun
fonctionnaire il faudra y avoir des
changements mais en tout cas il n'y a
pas de pression je pense que la question
pour les législateurs et les décideurs
c'est que nous avions toujours eu l'idée
qu'il y aurait une récession économique
des inconvénients économiques aux
principes mais que nous allions allions
pouvoir l'un de ces car ma première le
contrôle d'une tricoteuse sommes en
plein dans un choc économique majeur
la question c'est est ce qu'on veut
vraiment faire de plus de poids sur
notre économie
je pense que le gouvernement va dire que
l'union européenne non je suis fort
selon le calendrier ne changeront d'avis
à cette armée en tout cas il change
d'avis merci beaucoup de jeunes mecs
ternes ancien conseiller de tony blair
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et on en parle régulièrement les
conséquences économiques de cette crise
qui touche les étapes du monde entier
exemple avec rome qui débloque car 400
milliards d'euros pour venir en aide aux
entreprises l'italie qui compte moins de
décès que la veille avec six ans quatre
nouveaux décès aujourd'hui qui a passé
tout de même la barre des dix sept mille
morts
c'est toujours évidemment le pays le
plus endeuillé par le virus et l'aide
internationale continue de s'organiser
un avion avec dix tonnes de fournitures
médicales a atterri hier à rome en
provenance des émirats arabes unis
présent sur le tarmac luigi me met you
le ministre italien des affaires
étrangères
comme vous pouvez le voir ce matin
d'autres cadeaux sont arrivés ce sont
des cadeaux des émirats arabes unis et
les émirats arabes unis sont là de nos
amis
il est très important de vous dire que
la nuit dernière 9 millions de masques
sont arrivés en italie
je dis cela parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
solidarité en cours et cela il renforcé
par ce que nous achetons actuellement il
ya maintenant de très grand débat sur le
nombre de masques que nous achetons et
le nombre que nous recevons ce n'est pas
le problème
l'enjeu est de sauver des vies les
cadeaux arrivent ce que nous avons signé
dans les contrats arrivent aussi
on y est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que lorsque nous sauvons des vies et
protégeons nos médecins
le problème n'est pas ce que nous
achetons est ce que nous recevons c'est
ce que nous avons semé dans notre
politique étrangère c'est ainsi que nous
avons gagné le respect et l'amitié de
nombreuses personnes et de nombreux
gouvernements et hier il a une autre
grande manifestation de solidarité car
j'ai reçu les appels de nombreux
ministres des affaires étrangères qui
suit avec grande appréhension ce qui se
passe en italie
deuxième pays le plus endeuillé
l'espagne 13 mille morts au total et une
nouvelle hausse des décès journaliers
après un ralentissement 743 en 24 heures
le pays envisage donc un d'imposer le
port du masque mais c'est une denrée
rare là bas aussi
et certains sont sans scrupules exemple
en galice où deux millions d'unités ont
été volés dans un entrepôt industriel
montant du vol est estimé à près de 5
millions d'euros selon certains médias
locaux un homme d'affaires de la région
serait soupçonné il a été arrêté par les
forces de l'ordre locales et au japon
l'état d'urgence était déclarée pour
cette région dont tokyo et osaka mesures
prises par le premier ministre shinzo
abe face à la montée du nombre de cas
depuis deux semaines prévues pour un
mois l'état d'urgence permet aux
autorités de demander aux habitants de
limiter les sorties non essentiel et de
fermer certains commerces pas de
confinement obligatoire là bas ni de
sanction un plan daide record de 915
milliards d'euros également été annoncés
pour soutenir l'économie
c'est mon cas notamment avec l'accord du
conseil consultatif
je déclare par la présente l'état
d'urgence basée sur la loi spéciale que
vous puissiez ou non protéger votre
famille que vous aimez tout va dépendre
de vos actions là encore je vous demande
votre coopération
si nous sommes unis nous pouvons à
nouveau avancer avec espoir
je suis convaincu que nous vaincrons le
virus et que nous surmonterons les
preuves de cet état d'urgence
déclaration d'état d'urgence qui a fait
réagir les japonais tous critiquent la
prise de décision trop hâtive du
gouvernement je crois que cet art je
pense qu'il ya quelques problèmes
d'argent mais je pense aussi que nous
pouvons gagner notre vie
j'aimerais donc demandé une sorte de
soutien je suis sûr que certaines
personnes seront sans emploi
même si je travaille toujours j'espère
donc qu'il y aura une forme d' aide pour
ceux qui perdent leur emploi
[Musique]
justement non
j'espère qu'il y aura moins de contacts
entre humains que le risque d'infection
sera réduit et que de nombreuses
personnes ne seront pas infecté je pense
que c'est la bonne méthode
oui la vie serait très ennuyeuse non si
vous ne pouvez aller nulle part
alors dès que possible afin de retrouver
notre vie ordinaire je vais essayer de
me contrôler et de rester à la maison du
concert
maintenant que si le gouvernement avait
traité chacun des problèmes plus
rapidement je ne pense pas que le virus
se serait répandu le continent africain
davantage épargnés pour l'instant tout
cas que les etats-unis ou l'europe mais
la situation est inquiétante toutefois
le système de santé de certains pays est
il prêt à affronter une épidémie d'une
telle ampleur alors que la question se
pose focus en côte d'ivoire un centre de
dépistage en construction a été
vandalisée dans la banlieue d'abidjan
les habitants n'en veulent pas regarder
la police a dû intervenir et perd usage
de gaz lacrymogènes à yopougon
importantes communes populaires
d'abidjan
la tension reste vive au lendemain de la
destruction par des habitants d'un
centre de dépistage du coronavirus en
construction les manifestants disent
craindre que ce centre ne les expose à
des risques de contagion encore plus
élevé
[Applaudissements]
oui une situation qui a poussé le préfet
d'abidjan à se rendre sur place pour
tenter de rassurer la population
ne vous inquiétez pas toutes les
communes d'abidjan auront cessantes là
où facilité et pour donner l'information
c'est pas son moment pour les tests ça
pour les informations par mais vous y en
a qui ont la fièvre ce soit ou bien tout
à l'heure dracula tout ira q qui vont
tous et enfin que l'on des maux de gorge
damas qui vont se sentais bizarre ce
sont les premiers incidents de ce type
en côte d'ivoire encore relativement peu
touchés des mesures strictes ont été
prises pour lutter contre la propagation
du virus dans le pays mise en
quarantaine d'abidjan couvre-feu
nocturne sur tout le territoire
fermeture de tous les commerces non
essentiels des écoles et des lieux de
culte et interdiction des rassemblements
mais pas de confinement jusqu'à présent
mardi dernier le gouvernement a par
ailleurs annoncé un plan de soutien de
plus de deux milliards d'euros pour
faire face aux conséquences économiques
et sociales de la bande et c'est avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur cette crise du corps
d'un virus en france qui franchit la
barre des 10000 morts quatrième semaine
de confinement quelles peuvent être les
effets sur notre santé mentale
il y en a plein vous verrez et puis nous
parlerons des contrôles policiers des
associations dénoncent certains
contrôles violent qui aurait fuité sur
les réseaux sociaux depuis le début le
confinement
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est un père dit
d'interdire
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins il
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
il ya une première chose que je pense
qui est importante c'est que les états
que ce soit la france ou la belgique
reconnaissent cette situation reconnaît
ce qui a eu des adoptions illégales cela
concernait combien d'enfants
les chiffres exacts ne sont pas très
claires de plusieurs centaines donc
vraiment c'était orchestrée au plus haut
niveau en fait ce trafic d'enfants donc
vous avez été d'ailleurs toutes deux
victimes geparo ni l'amour j'ai reçu de
mes parents adoptifs je sens que cette
adoption n'est pas totalement légale
quoi pour vous vous étiez adopté de
manière tout à fait mal tout est légal
j'espère du fond du coeur que notre
procédure aboutira qu'un procure ans
passionnera pour notre histoire on
espère être les pionniers en la matière
parce qu'il ya d'autres pays qui sont
concernés et donc on espère pouvoir
ouvrir la porte aux institutions
européennes finalement
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de fine
stratégie peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour une demi heure d'information les
21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 7
avril la france fasse la barre des 10000
morts liés aux coronavirus annonce du
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon tout à l'heure et français qui
sont entrés dans leur quatrième semaine
de confinement qui va durer martel
edouard philippe à l'assemblée et il se
durcit même à paris où il ne sera plus
possible à partir de demain de faire du
sport entre 10h et 19h concernant le
port du masque plusieurs villes comme
nice cannes où sow souhaite le rendre
obligatoire mais restez chez vous c'est
donc le mot d'ordre si cet isolement
doit permettre d'endiguer la pandémie il
n'est pas sans effet sur la santé
mentale et peut occasionner un stress
post traumatique des sentiments de
frustration de confusion ou de colère
selon une étude parue dans le monde 700
milles en 7
nous verrons que nous ne sommes pas tous
égaux face à cette épreuve est en pleine
crise du coronavirus les contrôles des
forces de l'ordre fait débat des
associations dénoncent certains
contrôles policiers violents qui aurait
fuité sur les réseaux sociaux depuis le
début du confinement
plusieurs organisations les dénoncer
appel mini de l'intérieur et le
directeur général de la police au
respect des procédures
[Musique]
la france passe donc la barre des 10000
morts avec a10 mouillée 328 décès
précisément depuis le 1er mars liés à
cette épidémie annonce de jérôme celle
au mont peu avant 20 heures selon le
directeur général de la santé la france
n'est pas je cite encore au pic
épidémique mais dans la phase ascendante
il a également rappelé que le
confinement allait durer et appelle les
ehpad à remonter leurs besoins le plus
rapidement possible depuis le 1er mars
en additionnant les décès survenus à
l'hôpital et ceux survenus au sein des
établissements médico sociaux et en
particulier les ehpad
nous déplorons 10300 28 décès pour faire
face à l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes âgées atteintes ducobu de 19
les ehpad ont besoin de renfort je les
invite donc à remonter le plus vite
possible leurs besoins aux agences
régionales de santé avec des détails
avec des expressions précises pour que
nous leur trouvions rapidement et
collectivement des solutions
les autorités sanitaires recommandent le
port du masque alors que le gouvernement
y était hostile il ya encore quelques
jours alors faut-il oui ou non le porter
ce masque le ministre de la santé olivet
verrons a réaffirmé la position de la
france aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
décision de recommandations de port du
masque ni obligatoire ni recommandé en
tout cas à ce stade pour la population
générale
s'il s'avère que le port d'un masque en
population générale pouvait permettre de
renforcer l'efficacité du dispositif si
les recommandations des scientifiques
allaient dans ce sens alors nous serions
amenés à communiquer en ce sens mais à
ce stade je ne mendie la doctrine n'a
pas évolué et face à la pénurie de
masques plusieurs villes ont pris les
devants la métropole de bordeaux annonce
aujourd'hui son intention de commander
huit cent mille masque en tissu pour
équiper chacun des habitants de
l'agglomération
bordeaux qui s'est inspiré de l'exemple
niçois le maire question reste rosie
s'est engagé à fournir un masque en
tissu lavable et réutilisable à tous les
habitants et le port sera obligatoire
pour chaque sortie à paris anne hidalgo
elle prévoit d'en mettre deux millions à
disposition
des parisiens alors que la france est
entrée aujourd'hui dans sa quatrième
semaine de confinement edouard philippe
a prévenu que cela allait durer encore
de la présente dans de la séance des
questions au gouvernement écouter donc
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du confinement
et lors du confinement va durer et c'est
tout à fait difficile à supporter pour
beaucoup de français et j'en ai
parfaitement conscience mais c'est
indispensable si nous ne voulons pas
nous retrouver dans une situation qui
serait pire encore que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui déconfinement
pas à l'ordre du jour on l'aura compris
et les autorités qui serre la vis encore
un peu plus dès demain à paris les
activités sportives seront restreintes
de 10 heures à 19 heures c'est à dire
toute la journée sera désormais interdit
de pratiquer toute activité sportive
individuelle une mesure prévisible pour
certains exagéré pour d'autres qui
intervient alors que la capitale a à
nouveau été le théâtre de débordements
ce week-end ce qui avait d'ailleurs
alarmé le personnel soignant
actuellement quelques fois j'ai tout cas
beaucoup de monde c'est peut-être une
mesure fait ça tombe bien cette mesure
tenue des affluents sur la
certains endroits je pense quand même
faire un petit footing de temps en temps
c'est pas je sais pas si c'est
médicalement des conseillers je passe
mes amis d'algos a pris des conseils par
rapport à d des scientifiques pensent
que oui mais faut réfléchir parce que
c'est comparer un peu exagéré surtout
entre 10h et 19h enfin sont interdits
totalement une hausse cas c'est hyper
drastique c'est un peu difficile seront
interdites à 5h trouve ça un peu bizarre
en fait cet entre deux et le président
du conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy qui conseille emmanuel macron
était invité ce matin sur bfm tv il
envisage un confinement probablement
jusqu'à début mai le confinement est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel mais qui va
encore durer dans le temps plusieurs
semaines je pense qu'il vaut mieux le
dire d'emblée maintenant il est trop tôt
pour prévoir une date de sortie
ça nous mène probablement jusqu'à début
mai je n'irai pas plus loin sur la
précision parce que nous ne l'avons pas
mais le confinement et ses effets
psychologiques pour en parler nous
sommes avec marianne khedija docteur en
psychologie clinique et psychothérapeute
bonsoy ans maria merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france le confinement
est il pour beaucoup une épreuve
psychologique et quelles peuvent en être
les conséquences au alors déjà la
première chose que je voudrais signaler
c'est que effectivement c'est une balade
qui est pas facile qui demande beaucoup
d'adaptation et qui est stressante
ça dépend évidemment nos conditions de
vie est ce qu'on travaille à ce qu'on
est seul en chine et est ce qu'on est
avec des enfants voilà il ya beaucoup de
paramètres qui vont entrer en ligne de
compte mais on soit c'est pas une
une épreuve traumato jeunes c'est pas
une épreuve traumatisante
parce qu'on n'est pas si on n'est pas
exposé au virus soit mail ou pas dans
des conditions extrêmement grave sur le
plan de la santé
on n'est pas exposé à un risque de mort
personnel donc ça ne risque pas de
générer des traumatismes juste parce
qu'on est confiné les risques c'est bien
sûr l'ennui et l'agacement qui peuvent
être liés à nos conditions de vie
évidemment
et donc si ça se prolonge relativement
longtemps
ça peut emmener sur des terrains anxieux
ou des terrains dépressif et notamment
si on a des antécédents de ce type là
bien sûr ça va être un facteur de
vulnérabilité
alors vous disiez ça dépend évidemment
ça semble logique évidemment le logement
selon qu'on travaille ou non avec des
enfants ça veut dire clairement où nous
ne sommes pas tous égaux notamment
peut-être préparé dans sa tête à vivre
ce confinement ne sommes pas tous égaux
à la ville de la même manière les
conditions font que la situation est
plus ou moins stressant pour chacun
d'entre nous et puis après on a aussi
évidemment des caractéristiques
personnelles qui font qu'on est plus ou
moins flexibles aux changements plus ou
moins adaptable notamment les personnes
qui ont un grand besoin de contrôle qui
si on monte côté psychologique et un
petit peu plus rigide vont avoir plus de
difficultés à s'adapter
alors cette interview vide vous dites
capacités au changement ou non aux
changements parce que lens il peut être
assez redoutable chez certains d'entre
nous n'êtes pas oui donc ça peut être
difficile après ça c'est pour le coup
pas quelque chose de très compliqué à
occuper parce que finalement on peut on
peut trouver des occupations selon les
loisirs qu'on apprécie
la plupart d'entre nous avons quand même
accès à internet au moins dans une
certaine mesure à la télévision il peut
y avoir des tas d'autres loisirs non
connectés qui sont tout à fait
accessible donc l'ennui en fait c'est un
paramètre qui est vraiment important
pour notamment pas à glisser sur le
terrain de la dépression et pour ça le
meilleur conseil qu'on peut donner c'est
d'essayer de calais des activités à
avoir un planning en fait dans la
journée même si sur le fond on n'aurait
pas besoin de planning m'essayer
vraiment de se fixer dans la journée des
temps où on va être occupée et puis
d'être en ennui c'est pas en soi un
problème on peut avoir des temps mais
ils sont nécessairement déprimé alors
vous parlez de la question des enfants
ça concerne évidemment beaucoup de
français on sait voilà qu'on joue un
petit peu les rôles de professeurs avec
les enfants quel est l'avis de la
psychologue là dessus et sous c'est plus
facile finalement selon vous de vivre en
confinement avec des enfants ou plus
difficile où ça dépend des cartes
évidemment que ça va dépendre desquels
je pense que c'est pas simple c'est très
difficile de concilier éventuellement
vie professionnelle enseignement de ce
pourquoi tout le monde n'est pas
d'ailleurs compétents c'est assez
frustrant de combiner tout c'est toutes
ces casquettes en même temps donc les
parents je pense sont assez stressés ça
dépend aussi bien entendu de l'âge des
enfants
et puis leur tempérament aussi voilà
après j'ai voulu sortir le classique du
petit qui essaye de relativiser c'est un
moment de découverte profitons-en pour
passer du temps de qualité avec nos
enfants
quels sont les conseils justement aux
parents désespérés on voit certaines
petite parodie assez régulière sur
internet
manifestement il ya beaucoup de parents
qui voient là qu'ils sont un petit peu
sous pression quels sont les conseils
que vous donneriez à léon les conseils
ils vont être les mêmes pour les parents
et pour les enfants c'est d'essayer et
je sais que c'est pas simple mais
d'essayer de cadrer au temps possible
dans la journée des taux différenciés
pour donner des repères aux enfants
essayer de respecter bien sûr les
repères liés à l'alimentation ou couché
tous les repères classiques qu'on peut
avoir comme terre par exemple pendant
les temps de vacances mais elle a essayé
de les maintenir
et puis ne pas hésité à impliquer les
enfants dans des tâches de la maison eux
ça les valorise ça leur donne un petit
peu de contrôle aussi par exemple faire
la cuisine et des pour le ménage des
choses comme ça voilà c'était petites
choses il faut vraiment essayer
d'impliquer les enfants et leur signifie
aussi qu'il ya des espaces et des temps
pour les parents où ils sont pas
forcément tout le temps les bienvenus
ils doivent respecter une certaine dans
l'intimité pour les parents les vacances
puisqu'on est en vacances il ya pas
beaucoup de différence ça peut
occasionner chez eux un petit stress sur
ya moins de devoir peut-être moins de
structures l'appel évidemment des écrans
aux cadets la vie de la petite fille là
dessus alors les écrans évidemment on
sait que c'est un facteur de risque pour
les enfants un petit peu des grands
c'est possible ça dépend usage il faut
ajuster évidemment en ce moment je pense
que la plupart des parents sur une
augmentation du temps d'écran pour avoir
un petit peu plus de temps tranquille de
leur côté il faut quand même essayer d'y
faire attention parce que souvent bon
bah on va payer le retour de bâton un
petit peu plus tard avec des enfants qui
vont être plus excités moins attentifs
et puis quand ils vont quand il va
falloir essayer de reprendre l'école ça
va ça va être compliqué donc il faut
faire attention à limiter les écrans les
enfants peut se divertir aussi autrement
qu'avec une tablette on en revient à
cette fameuse stratégie de déconfinement
on a entendu edouard philippe nous
donner aucune durée nous dire que ça va
justement durée mais sans perspective de
fin est ce que ça c'est bon pour le
moral est ce que c'est pas justement
l'un des facteurs peut-être les plus
stressants pour l'être humain de ne pas
savoir de ne pas avoir de perspective
oui je pense qu'effectivement c'est
stressant après le stress on n'en mesure
pas non plus quand il reste dans des
proportions
limitez donc malheureusement on ne peut
pas avoir d'indications plus précises
mme la stratégie que je conseillerai
c'est d'essayer de voir un petit peu
loin c'est à dire 1 - 3 4 semaines en
espérant qu'ils aient pas de déception
d'ici là mais vraiment il faut partir
sur le principe que il va falloir
s'ajuster à cette situation encore pour
un moment
il essayait de planifier aussi loin que
possible une autre mauvaise nouvelle en
tout cas pour les sportifs qui ont
peut-être besoin de soupape de
décompression l'activité sportive
interdit désormais à paris alors c'est
un peu la double peine si j'ose dire
parce que ce sont souvent les personnes
qui habitent dans des appartements qui
n'ont pas de maison avec desjardins est
ce que selon vous c'est une bonne mesure
alors moi ce que j'ai compris c'est pas
que c'était interdit c'est que ce serait
dur à 19 heures enfin voilà c'est pas
interdit complètement ça laisse quand
même des plages horaires importante le
matin elle soit pour le faire et
effectivement l'activité physique quelle
qu'elle soit c'est pas forcément du
footing on peut aussi faire du de
l'actif physique l'activité physique à
domicile mais l'activité physique c'est
une très bonne pratique en période de
stress parce que quand on est stressé on
va sécréter des hormones qui vont
s'accumuler dans le corps étendre nos
muscles
donc effectivement pouvoir décharger
cette énergie là d'une façon saine
c'est ça permet vraiment d'apaiser les
tensions quels sont justement les autres
palliatifs faire de la gym devant sa
télé peut-être de la méditation il ya
des conseils sur ce point oui la
méditation la cuisine tout ce qui va
vous distrait en fait tout ce qui va
vous relaxer elle il ya plein de
techniques de relaxation qu'il
fonctionne bien aussi des activités
sportives plus ou moins tente le pilates
etc
occupez vous essayez de faim et l'idée
c'est vraiment de ne pas partir sur
j'attends que le temps passe parce que
si vous faites ça que l'amour ça va être
déprimant donc c'est plutôt essayer de
rythme et ses journées avec des
activités un peu régulières à des
horaires qui ont du sens ce peut-être de
faire la même chose tous les mardis tous
les mercredis voilà d'essayer de créer
des moutis n'ont fait qu'ils vont
redonner un rythme à une semaine qui
pourrait paraître extrêmement aux notes
qu'on va tous finir grands cuisiniers
merci marianne qui est via docteur en
psychologie clinique et psychothérapeute
merci d'avoir été avec nous sofiane 21
ans livreur chez amazon se rendait chez
ses parents aux ulis avant son travail
de nuit sans attestation de sortie
sofiane prend peur et court à la vue de
la police rapidement rattrapé il est
encerclé par les policiers la scène
elle a été filmée par les habitants il
accuse des policiers de violences
aggravées lors d'un contrôle et porte
plainte auprès du parquet d'evry un
reportage signé mona amoud et l'or
[Musique]
depuis le début du confinement des
vidéos de contrôle policier violent en
banlieue parisienne affluent sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'une d'elles concerne l'interpellation
brutale de sofiane 21 ans aux ulis dans
le département de l'essonne
un jeune homme inconnu des services de
police sur ces images filmées par des
habitants on le voit à terre ne montrant
aucune résistance
rapidement maîtrisé par un policier on
l'entend demandé aux agents d'arrêter
ensuite sofiane est emmené sous un
porche d'immeuble
il est à nouveau mise à terre puis se
met à crier d'après la vidéo il a été
frappé à coups de pied et de matraque
télescopique à plusieurs reprises les
agents sont accusés d'avoir touché les
parties intimes du jeune homme
quatre jours d'itt et et lyon étaient
prescrits sami mollahs qui l'avocat de
la victime ne comprends pas la violence
de cette interpellation
c'est pour moi une agression gratuite
extrêmement graves commises par des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique en réunion à plusieurs sur une
personne qui n'était pas un danger pour
quiconque qu'il n'avait pas commis
d'infraction qui avait peut-être oubli
sur l'attestation mais qui pouvait être
verbalisé pour sa question
il avait une raison pour laquelle il est
sorti il entrer dans les critères
traumatisée le jeune homme ne souhaite
pas s'exprimer dans les médias selon son
avocat même en période de confinement le
cas de son client n'est pas une
exception que la même chose se déroule
sur différents territoires de la
république à différents endroits où on
voit que le dénominateur commun c'est
police les banlieues à chaque fois les
effectifs sont différents les personnes
sont différentes les lieux sous
différents quel est le dénominateur
commun si ce n'est que à chaque fois ça
se déroule en banlieue et que les
auteurs de ces agressions sont des
policiers
nous avons montré un extrait de
l'interpellation de sofiane à rocco
contento secrétaire départemental paris
unité sgp police
clairement quand vous
et ces images daes que est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que cette cette
personne là elle est là elle a fait
preuve de réveillon écoutez je ne sais
pas moi l'image ne choque pas du tout
j'ai vu pire que ça il faut savoir que
cette personne n'a été interpellé
bon visiblement pour le motif qu'elle
n'avait pas son attestation
on n'a pas de sens sur cette image
souvent on amène au sol pour le
menottage c'est comme ça qu'on fait
parce que beaucoup de personnes ne
veulent pas se laisser menotter debout
et c'est très compliqué donc on amène au
sol pour menotter
sur ce que j'ai vu les collègues ont
pratiqué des gestes techniques de police
et d'interpellation mais j'ai rien vu de
choquant mais j'ai pas vu d'atemi j'ai
pas vu de coup de pied j'ai pas vu de
coup de poing j'imagine que dans cette
affaire il y aura des dépôts de pain du
ciel que cette personne va déposer
plainte contre les collègues et comme
mes collègues vont déposer par contre
cette personne et c'est la justice qui
fera la lumière sur cette affaire
rocco contento estime que la police
réagit de manière proportionnée et
refuse de parler de violences policières
or ben écoutez moi je récuse le terme de
violences policières ça fait des années
qu'on me pose la question
une personne je vous le répète elle se
fait interpeller pour un motif qui est
légitime si la personne elle se trouve
elle est interpellée elle estime qu'elle
n'a pas fait l'objet d'une
interpellation arbitraire libre halde
allait déposer plainte à l'egypte
sofiane a déposé plainte contre x pour
violences aggravées en réunion et
non-assistance à personne en danger
pour le moment la famille dans la tente
des suites de l'anc est menée par le
procureur et pour parler de ces
contrôles policiers avec parfois des
accusations de violences ou non nous
sommes avec nabil boudi avocat bonsoir
on a dit là vous dis merci d'être avec
nous on connaissait les relations
souvent tendues entre la police et les
habitants de ces quartiers sensibles
certains habitants en tout cas est ce
que cette situation de confinement
exacerbe encore plus les tensions selon
vous c'est important de rappeler que ces
violences policières sont résistantes
est pas nouvelle elle existe dans ces
départs dans ces quartiers
particulièrement depuis tant d'années le
confinement ne fait qu'aggraver la
situation
on peut le rappeler
changez catégoriquement la donne
aujourd'hui qui reste sous l'ère du
numérique c'est à dire que maintenant
ces violences policières sont beaucoup
plus visibles
donc elle existait avant aujourd'hui à
son fils mais elles sont diffusées sur
les réseaux sociaux et dans le contexte
de confinement
les personnes sont de plus en plus j'ai
donc depuis leur fenêtre alors il va
filmer ces scènes qui je le rappelle il
existe depuis malheureusement trop
longtemps dans le contexte de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
avec la mise en place d'une infraction
maintenant qui est le non respect du
confinement qui est une intervention
s'est embellie des on a vu on voit des
images passées on voit des personnes se
faire contrôler alors porteuse union
d'une attestation d'envoi des violences
qui sont légitimes qui sont excessives
qui sont dirigés vers une partie de la
population je pense qu'il faut pas avoir
peur de le dire aujourd'hui il faut
tenir un discours clair mais surtout un
discours de vérité
il ya des disparités donc dans la dans
les consoles
et puis dans leurs conséquences on se
souvient tous des images qui ont été
diffusées au début du conflit on ne
voyait beaucoup d les parisiens se
balader dans les abords des quais de
seine sur les jardins des tuileries et
au trocadéro toutes ces personnes là
n'étaient pas en conformité avec le
confinant donc ce qui serait souhaitable
dans ce contexte ce serait que la
pédagogie qui est mise en place pour les
habitants des grandes villes soit aussi
la même que pour les habitants de
banlieue je vous dis clairement qu'il ya
eu plus de contrôle dans l'est dans les
quartiers dits sensibles
clairement ce que je dis pour être
parfaitement précis je précise que la
pédagogie au met en oeuvre dans les
grandes villes doit être appliquée
également dans les quartiers sensibles
n'évite pas le confinement de la même
manière les habitants dans les quartiers
oculaires sont souvent dans des foyers
exigu avec nombreuses donc le
confinement en tant que telle est encore
plus difficile et j'ai envie de vous
dire que d'habiter par exemple genève
dans un appartement spacieux donc le
contexte nécessite en urgence que tout
le monde fasse preuve de retenue et que
l'urgence c'est bien sûr que chacun
respecte les compliments mais s'il ya
des problèmes liés à cette contravention
elles doivent en aucun abus ni sur des
violences policières à nos confrères du
canard enchaîné avait rapporté une note
du ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner selon lui un seul
ont en tout cas le canard enchaîné le
respect du confinement dans les
quartiers populaires ne serait pas une
priorité quelle est la réaction de
l'avocat de réflexion autour de cette
information a été diffusée dans vos
conseils ce soit que les services de
police ou en tout cas le ministère de
l'intérieur considère que si ces
personnes ne sont pas confinés qu'elle
est contrat que le comité ne c'est une
main grave que d'ordre n'est pas c'est
pas une accusation gelé uniquement un
commentaire sur cette dépêche soit
contenu des contextes et des relations
souvent difficiles entre les jeunes et
la police il vaut mieux éviter des
contrôlés par la position c'est la
suivante
moi je suis d'avis qu'il est nécessaire
qu'il est indispensable d'agir avec
pédagogie plus qu'à l'abri son film si
la personne ne respecte pas les
obligations liées à l'état d'urgence
donc être en possession d'une
attestation de sortie et même si les
manuscrits j'attire l'attention sur ce
point jusqu'à des personnes qui ont été
violentés
alors qu'elle était en elle était en
possession d'une des stations non
inscrits
rien ne l'interdît dans les textes si la
personne n'a pas d'imprimante izel que
recopier à lamastre mater station et
malgré ça on sait qu'il ya des personnes
qui ont été violentés
donc il faut un appel au calme
ces violences doivent cesser et surtout
il faut une prise de parole de la part
du ministère de l'intérieur
vous l'avez rappelé le début les
violences ont augmenté dans les
quartiers notamment avec ce confinement
qui est difficile à respecter pour ses
repas selon vous le couvre feu pourrait
être une des solutions pour apaiser les
tensions ou star en pire est peut-être
une situation déjà difficile
moi je suis pas certain que qu'une
mesure encore plus liberticides viendra
régler le cas solution ce qu'il faut et
j'ai encore ma répéter c'est faire
preuve de pédagogie et là encore le il
faut que les consignes soient claires il
ya eu une confusion de la part du
gouvernement dans la mise en place de ce
document les attestations ont évolué les
motifs de sorties ont évolué et là on
voit qu'à paris sont en train d'évoluer
maintenant il ya une attestation qui est
numérisé les motifs pareil vont changer
donc pour que la population accepte
maintenant il faut que les consignes
soient claires donc pas d'urgence
pas de poudre au feu pardon le
couvre-feu dans ses quartiers à mon avis
ne va faire qu'augmenter les tontons il
faut le confinement soit appliquée et
les mesures de contrôle soient
similaires c'est un maquillage à paris
merci beaucoup à nabil abu dis d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt français
c'est la fin de cette émission un peu
écourtée vous le savez désormais en
raison cette crise du corona à virus qui
nous pousse adaptés nous aussi nos
programmes en attendant ces derniers
continuent avec des magazines pour un
complet sur l'actualité ce sera demain à
9 heures du matin
air france est excellent en fin de
soirée à tous
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants de la
première heure de notre administration a
été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15 ans
de travail de fond fait par les
analystes prions clair ils ont prêché la
guerre sainte et le problème c'est qu'on
les a trop longtemps les équipes il ya
eu un espèce de d